[Música]
la justicia de Estados Unidos condena a
18 años de cárcel al líder del grupo
ultraderechista ozkeepers por el asalto
al Capitolio se trata de la condena más
alta por el intento de golpe de estado
del 6 de enero de 2021 Y responde a
delitos de sedición y conspiración
amnistía internacional Pide a la
fiscalía de Perú que investigue la
responsabilidad del estado en los
ataques letales de la fuerza pública
contra civiles durante las
manifestaciones en contra de la
destitución y la detención de Pedro
Castillo tenemos análisis
Rusia empezó el despliegue de armas
nucleares tácticas en belarus mientras a
los Soldados del ejército de Moscú toman
el relevo al grupo Wagner en backmuth
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición en Estados Unidos
porque la Justicia del país emitió hoy
la sentencia más elevada hasta el
momento por el asalto al Capitolio del 6
de enero de 2021 el líder del grupo
ultraderechista ozkeepers fue condenado
a 18 años de cárcel al ser hallado
culpable de delitos de rebelión y
sedición stewards un ex militar que
estudió derecho en la prestigiosa
universidad de Yale encabezó la
insurrección Armada que pretendía evitar
el traspaso democrático de poderes entre
Donald Trump y el presidente Joe biden
Esto es lo que dijeron los abogados del
condenado
No hay forma de que él fuera el líder o
el director de lo que sucedió el 6 de
enero era solo un objetivo conveniente
los keepers eran un objetivo conveniente
el departamento de Justicia los miró Y
dijo Oh aquí están los chivos
expiatorios de lo que sucedió el 6 de
enero en otras noticias de Estados
Unidos este miércoles el Ultra
conservador ron de santis lanzó su
candidatura a las primarias del partido
republicano en un evento virtual en
Twitter con el propietario de la red
social elon musk sin embargo el anuncio
Fue bastante atropellado y objeto de
burlas tanto de sus rivales como de la
comunidad de internet
pasa en las mejores familias
Este es el primer corte que sufrió David
Sax el presentador de la postulación
presidencial del republicano ron de
santis pero no fue el último
todo pasó en Twitter spaces y lo vivió
en primera persona su ceo y lo más uno
de los hombres más ricos del mundo
experimentando los mismos problemas que
el resto de los mortales
[Música]
el esperado de Santi se acabó emergiendo
de las profundidades del internet
los internautas no perdonaron hashtags
en Twitter como error en el lanzamiento
estrellado y desaster En referencia a su
nombre una fiesta del Meme a la que se
sumó el expresidente Donald Trump
principal rival de The santis en las
primarias republicanas
incluso perdió un Twitter spaces con
presencia de Hitler o el [__]
pero no solo Donald Trump el biff llegó
hasta el presidente Joe biden quien
podría enfrentarse a de santis siempre y
cuando este derrote a Trump y a su
Ingenio
cambiamos de información vamos a Perú
porque amnistía internacional Pide a la
fiscalía de la nación que investigue los
funcionarios hasta los demás alto nivel
por sus responsabilidades en los ataques
letales de la fuerza pública contra
civiles durante las protestas desatadas
en diciembre tras la destitución y la
detención del expresidente Pedro
Castillo ahora desde Lima Contamos con
Erika Guevara ella es directora para las
Américas de amnistía internacional y
vamos a hablar del informe racismo letal
ejecuciones extrajudiciales y uso
ilegítimo de la fuerza por los cuerpos
de seguridad de Perú Erika buenas tardes
para usted Muchísimas gracias por estar
con nosotros en France 24 le pregunto
ustedes analizaron 52 casos de personas
fallecidas o heridas qué conclusiones
extraen
Rosa lo que hemos encontrado en esta
investigación que se enfoca en el uso
desproporcional de la fuerza en el uso
letal de la fuerza por parte de los
cuerpos de seguridad tanto policiales
como militares es que en Perú se han
cometido ejecuciones extrajudiciales con
la intención de castigar a las personas
que salían a protestar que tomaban las
calles particularmente en comunidades
históricamente marginalizadas de pueblos
indígenas y campesinos por lo que
nuestra evidencia demuestra que hubo un
sesgo racista para atacar de manera
generalizada a estas personas inclusive
se han asesinado a jóvenes que ni
siquiera participaban en las protestas
que se habían acercado por curiosidad o
que simplemente eran transeúntes
cercanos a una manifestación
precisamente porque los cuerpos de
seguridad militares y policiales
hicieron ese uso excesivo de la fuerza
un uso letal de la fuerza en la que se
utilizó armas de guerra como rifles de
alto alcance rifles Gali entre otros que
están prohibidos bajo las normas
internacionales para el control de
protestas y Erika en base a sus
hallazgos ustedes indican que se trató
de una estrategia organizada del estado
o de casos aislados
Rosa claramente dado los patrones las
repeticiones el uso de las fuerzas
letales en diferentes o localidades del
país nos demuestra que hubo una
intención de castigo organizada y Por
ende hemos pedido a la fiscal de la
nación que investigue no solo a los
perpetradores directos es decir a
quienes jalaron el gatillo sino que
también a las altas autoridades que a
pesar de saber que se estaban cometiendo
esas violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
no hicieron nada para prevenirlos o que
quizás ordenaron el ataque Y ustedes
señalan que existe riesgo de impunidad
por qué
bueno hemos estado documentando en las
últimas semanas
algunas alertas de preocupación frente a
retrasos y omisiones en las
investigaciones realizadas por la
fiscalía nacional la fiscal nacional ha
creado un cuerpo especial un equipo
especial de diez personas Fiscales para
la investigación exclusiva que han
atraído todas las carpetas de
investigación a Lima pero hemos
escuchado de las víctimas en ayacucho en
andahuaylas el temor que tienen de no
tener cercanía ni participación en los
procesos de investigación la lejanía que
tendrán los fiscales de las regiones en
donde se cometieron estas violaciones a
los derechos humanos y la propia fiscal
ha reconocido la carencia de recursos e
inclusive de experticia por ejemplo
experticia balística para poder realizar
las investigaciones Y hasta qué punto
consideran que la investigación llegará
puede llegar hasta Dina boluarte que ha
sido citada a declarar
bueno rosa es importante mencionar que
estas violaciones a los derechos humanos
en el contexto de protestas también se
dan en el marco de un estado de
emergencia en la cual la presidenta
boluarte ASUME toda El Comando verdad
tanto de las operaciones policiales como
de las operaciones militares además bajo
la constitución del Perú la presidenta
es la jefa máxima de las fuerzas
militares Por lo cual hay una
responsabilidad directa tanto por
omisión o por orden de las atrocidades
cometidas por las fuerzas de seguridad
Erika pues se nos acaba el tiempo para
continuar abordando esta cuestión pero
muchísimas gracias por compartir su
trabajo aquí en France 24
nosotros vamos ahora a velarus porque el
presidente Alexander lukashenko anunció
que Rusia ya empezó a desplegar las
armas nucleares tácticas en territorio
bielorruso un movimiento que materializa
lo que ya anunció en marzo el presidente
Vladimir Putin según la agencia Tas el
ministro de defensa de Rusia sergeibu
aseguró que la decisión se ha tomado
como respuesta a la escalada de amenazas
en sus fronteras que recordemos que en
los últimos días la región rusa de
velgorot fronteriza con Ucrania ha
recibido ataques reivindicados por
milicias que combaten a favor de kiev en
esta guerra
y tanto Bruselas como Washington han
condenado al despliegue el portavoz de
exteriores de la Unión Europea lamentó
un paso que aumenta la tensión
escuchemos ahora la reacción del
departamento de estado de Estados Unidos
continuamos fuertemente este acuerdo es
el último ejemplo del comportamiento
irresponsable que hemos visto de Rusia
desde que comenzó esta invasión a gran
escala en Ucrania un año atrás queremos
dejar claro que el uso de armas químicas
biológicas o armas nucleares en este
conflicto será respondido con duras
consecuencias en respuesta a este
reporte agregó que no hemos visto
ninguna razón para ajustar nuestra
postura estratégica nuclear o algún
indicio de que Rusia vaya a lanzar un
ataque de este tipo en otras noticias de
la guerra en Ucrania tras asegurar que
tienen el control total de bakmut este
jueves el grupo Wagner empezó a entregar
al ejército regular de Moscú sus
posiciones en la ciudad donde recordemos
Mercenario rusos y ejército ucraniano
han combatido durante meses en la
batalla más larga de esta guerra sin
embargo kiev continúa sin reconocer La
derrota
el grupo Wagner inició su repliegue
debajoot tras el anuncio de la captura
de la ciudad la semana pasada Los
mercenarios van a dejar su espacio al
propio ejército ruso así se lo comunicó
a sus tropas el líder y fundador del
grupo Jeff y pregosin
Qué pasa muchachos Eso es todo nos
mudamos en 10 15 minutos todos se van
antes del primero de junio descansaremos
nos prepararemos y luego obtendremos una
nueva tarea
se espera que esta retirada termine
antes de fin de
mayorigosin muy crítico con Los Altos
funcionarios de defensa de Rusia ha
dicho que estarán listos para regresar
si el ejército no puede controlar la
situación
Estos son beaver y dolic en el momento
en el que el ejército tenga un momento
difícil ellos se plantarán y bloquearán
el paso al ejército de ucraniano desde
Ucrania lo ven como un reagrupamiento
por las bajas que han provocado al grupo
Wagner durante meses la viceministra de
defensa ucraniana reconoció en Telegram
el intercambio de tropas con Rusia
en las afueras de bahamut el enemigo ha
reemplazado las unidades de Wagner con
fuerzas del ejército regular dentro de
la ciudad misma quedan combatientes de
Wagner
bahamut ha sido la batalla más larga y
Sangrienta de la guerra Wagner reconoció
más de 20.000 bajas mientras Ucrania
está a la espera de realizar una
contraofensiva en la que pueda recuperar
un enclave simbólico Aunque convertido
en escombros
cambiamos de información vamos a Londres
Reino Unido donde un vehículo se estampó
contra la entrada del número 10 de
downing Street recordemos la sede del
ejecutivo británico y residencia del
Primer Ministro sin embargo no se
conocen daños ni víctimas del incidente
y la policía ha restado a un hombre
mientras Investiga el motivo de los
hechos
y cerramos con un gran avance médico y
es que un equipo de neurocientíficos en
Suiza ha conseguido que un hombre
parapléjico vuelva a caminar tras más de
una década paralizado ampliamos en el
siguiente informe
el reto era difícil volver a caminar por
sí mismo el miércoles este milagro
médico lo consiguió en Suiza girtian un
erland desde 40 años que quedó
paralítico hace 12 años tras sufrir una
lesión medular en un accidente de
ciclismo ahora gracias a un nuevo
dispositivo puede activar sus
movimientos con su mente la interfaz
utiliza algoritmos basados en La
Inteligencia artificial para
descodificar grabaciones cerebrales en
tiempo real luego convierte sus
intenciones de movimiento en impulsos
que acaban activando los músculos de sus
piernas esta conexión entre el cerebro y
la médula espinal se denomina fuente
digital
para crear este puente digital tenemos
que hacer dos operaciones la primera es
en el cerebro donde implantamos dos
dispositivos en la corteza motora la
región responsable del control motor y
luego hacemos una segunda operación a
nivel de la médula espinal donde
implantamos electrodos en la región de
la médula espinal responsable de la
activación de las piernas es Entonces
cuando estos dos implantes se ponen en
servicio y se comunican cuando se
produce la masa desde que recibió los
dos implantes garchan entrena todos los
días
dorsal puedo controlar la estimulación
con el pensamiento puedo decir cuando
empezar y cuándo parar la estimulación
controlo totalmente lo que hace la
estimulación y eso me da mucha libertad
el neurocientífico francés
y su equipo suizo están a la cabeza de
este logro científico resultado de más
de una década de trabajo lo que
realmente nos sorprendió fue que
utilizando este puente digital pudo
recuperar el uso de músculos que habían
estado paralizados durante muchos años
esto sugiere que las conexiones
nerviosas han vuelto a crecer en
respuesta al entrenamiento con el puente
digital antes de éxito el equipo se
dispone a iniciar un ensayo similar para
devolver la funcionalidad a los brazos y
a las manos la esperanza es poder ayudar
a los pacientes con infartos a recuperar
sus funciones motoras
hasta aquí las noticias gracias por su
atención
[Música]